on va faire une petite interview a redit
view vous êtes prêt
sur
[Musique]
la bouche marbre la rétine galles
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment à
rien je suis si je pense que j'ai je me
suis précipité sur un petit bout de pain
avec du jambon de bayonne en arrivant il
vous reste sur l'estomac non celui
j'aurais dû avoir la patience d'attendre
pour la guinée correctement la voilà
voilà quand vous regardez le matin dans
la glace vous dites quoi je regarde si
je suis raccords pour la barbe ah ah oui
parce que si je peux gagner encore un
jour ça va mais si c'est en tournage
jeudi me manque c'est rien lâché 2 mm de
plus alors j'ai du boulot non c'est très
difficile ou et non mais je peux dire
c'est aussi dur que quand vous étiez
petit vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui
un adulte et n'importe quel adulte et
mardi c'est arrivé votre plus belle
histoire d'amour
je n'aime que des belles histoires
d'amour je n'ai pas eu une plus belle
que d'autres aient beaucoup hein un
paquet aïe je regardais en préparant les
nations à ces normes non mais c'est vrai
paquet des filles sublimes ont plus
sublime pourquoi parce que je suis un
être x qui a
[Applaudissements]
montré le bout cas quand on est médecin
jusqu'à sa mort il avait risqué alors
quand on vous demande un autographe vous
écrivez quoi ah bah ça dépend en
principe j'écris toujours dans la rue ou
sur un livre dans la rue pendant dans la
rue j'écris bons souvenirs
dans les livres jeunes
j'ai pas besoin de faire grand-chose jeu
mais c'est bien vrai et c'est au titre
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois je pleure uniquement à l'occasion
du mort ouais c'est qu'il a tout le
monde est mort le problème c'est que si
vous voulez j'ai fait une émission
récemment avec un type qui m'a mis
devant une affiche de tout le monde il
est beau tout le monde il est gentil
qu'ils tournent un film j'avais réalisé
et qui me dit il ya longtemps il a vu
cette affiche et oui bien sûr et en
temps et alors qu'est ce que ça vous
fait de la revoir alors j'ai vu jean
pierre rassam et jean yanne présente
jean pierre rassam exit way un scénario
de gérard cyr et jean yanne publiera ci
indique michel magne plus de michel
magne avec bernard blier et des mois
vous seriez qu en vous si vous aviez une
baguette magique mon ventre j'aurai des
abdominaux comme des plaques de chocolat
je rêve de ça
ne me balader sur les plages et que
se précipite sur moi pour avoir mal
vous trouvez comment
ben
dilla rondouillette c'est sympa
robillard 1 c'est sympa on échappe quand
on n'est pas lui ça bah ouais
non c'est vrai il ya un avantage
considérable à être peur alors ça c'est
un truc que j'ai pu observer cent mille
fois quand on est poilu et barbu on peut
être gros et habillés avec des choses
rigolotes oui c'est vrai un veau points
oui mais j'ai un carlos carlos
éminemment sympathique jean pierre coffe
il voit là il est gros bon ben c'est
bien il à la barre il peut se mettre des
tee-shirts de couleur des chemises
hawaïennes bon vous voyez pas je peins
comme ça non
quel péché qui vous tente le plus gênant
c'est l'avarice parce que grave crise
c'est le peuple c'est le seul péché
qu'on peut avoir même quand on est
pauvre
[Rires]
jean yanne que diriez-vous de plus
négatif sur vos de plus négatif sur moi
vraiment pour vous auto iv c'est pour
mosley pour nous cela est maintenant
tout le monde est une fois pour toutes
j'aurais vraiment pu faire mieux ouais
c'est vrai
moi je vous le dis j'ai vraiment pu
faire mieux si je n'avais pas été aussi
flemmards mais
en fait même pas flemmard je n'ai jamais
jamais été un battant et donc d'accès
difficile je m'arrête ouais donc je
n'aurais jamais pu être sportif ou
franck leboeuf moi j'aurais donné un
coup de pied mais un mec m'a effleuré le
genou on en mange pas parfait
et le football de ces jeux c'est exact
vous avez dit pendant longtemps
j'ai un gros défaut par rapport au sport
je l'est aussi par rapport à ce
spectacle je reconnais pas les gens
alors évidemment j'ai une admiration
sans borne pour les mecs qui disent
machin qui passe à machin qu'il fasse un
match entier
vous adorez thierry roland mais oui
parce que moi je vois un type qui pousse
un ballon qui donne un autre mais qui
donne un coup de ballon et puis à le
stade se lève et j'ai même pas vu quand
celle d'un che comment ils font il met
des numéros sur le dos des gens à mon
avis non il faut associer le livre
papier m même les noms mal en der
les noms aussi qui avez vous le plus
envie d'épater
en suisse vous feriez quoi s'il vous
restait 24 heures à vivre ce qui est
bien c'est qu'en ce moment cette
question c'est vraiment gay votre
émission le sait vraiment c'est vrai
si j'avais 24 heures je ferai pas grand
chose parce qu'en 24 heures je n'aurai
pas le temps de faire tout ce que j'ai à
faire et que j'aurais déjà dû faire
ouais mais je crois que j'essaierai
d'être avec eux les gens qui m'aiment
bien mais pas trop pour pas leur faire
de chagrin ouais je me ferai un petit
plateau télé ouais je vais pouvoir et un
petit whisky et je mettrai la téloche et
voilà voilà c'est terrible c'est
terrible alors que vous allez pas prier
dans une église dans un sens que je vais
vous dire très franchement à 24 heures
ça sert plus à rien
salut
tu te fous de ma gueule tu vas pas te
repartir maintenant 24
sélectionnés comme vous c'est ça le
problème est beaucoup plus
miséricordieux non pas du tout ce que
dieu m'a fait à son image
mais qu'il faut c'est bien ce christ et
vous y serez surpris le surnom qu'on
vous donne que vous haïssez non non moi
ça me dérange pas les surnoms de toute
façon les on évolue on les oublie lens
qui me ce qui me ce qui met ce qui
m'énerve c'est quand les gens allant
moins - maintenant c'est quand les gens
ne me tutoie dans la rue mais il me
bouscule alors jaloux savez
je ne paraît pourtant il ya tellement de
gens qui vous ont jeté non non mais ça
dépend qui aussi je vois une fille
longiligne
les bagues aînés de nylon celui sétois
s'approche de moi qui vit dans un
souffle
[Musique]
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse
la survie enfin le snj a pas d'accord si
c'est après l'aller 1 il ya quand on y
mourut
ce qui nous énerve le plus en vo
jeu pas le courage de de dire non à des
allées chose qui m'emmerde à mourir
dit bon allez le faire est-ce que vous
énerve le plus chez moi
non pourquoi non non j'ai pas d'argent
on peut tout se dire ce soir non non je
sais bien nommé - non pourquoi vous
m'énervez pendre c'est vrai oh non c'est
sûr oui bon je serais pas venu gens
c'est un nombre même un peu oui non mais
je même une certaine passion parce qu'il
est vrai que parce que j'aime bien que
je sois toujours en noir ça que je
ne leur dis tu abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou